bien mes chers amis quelques mots
quelques mois mon tour pour vous dire le
plaisir que je sais partagée de vivre
ces moments militants avec vous et je
voudrais vraiment très sincèrement salué
cette force militante incroyable que
vous représentez vous qui allez sur les
quais des gares distribuer la bonne
parole à 6 heures du matin parfois une
heure après être allé coller qui est sur
les marchés le dimanche matin là encore
pour tracter je voudrais vous dire en
tant qu'élu toute la reconnaissance qui
est la nôtre pour cette force militante
que vous incarnez et avoue
particulièrement les jeunes
merci merci à vous et je dois vous dire
l'émotion qui était la mienne en venant
ici au touquet dans la voiture me
rappelant finalement la dernière
université d'été le dernier campus
auquel j'avais assisté comme militant
j'étais debout au fond de la salle
c'était en 2001 et honnêtement personne
et surtout pas moi pouvait imaginer que
l'année d'après le campus d'y aller
comme plus jeune député de france
à 28 ans et cette fois là sur la tribune
les jeunes engagés vous allez au combat
tout est possible pour vous
je voudrais surtout vous dire évidemment
l'immense joie que nous partageons qui
est celle en ce mois de septembre 2015
d'être dans une famille politique qui
donne une bien autre image que celle
qu'elle avait les années précédentes la
fierté de militer et retrouver les
républicains sont rassemblés on est dans
le débat d'idées et toute cette
construction nous la devons à quelqu'un
qui dans la campagne interne avait fait
le serment de donner le meilleur de
lui-même pour rassembler ce
rassemblement aujourd'hui il est là et
nous le devons à nicolas sarkozy et
c'est parce qu'il y a c'est parce qu'il
ya cette union parce qu'il vit à ce
changement d'image parce qu'il ya ce
rassemblement que nous avons commencé à
mettre de vrais victoire sur la route
des républicains et en particulier celui
qui vous parle a eu la chance de porter
nos couleurs dans un département qui
comme de nombreux départements en france
au mois de mars a basculé le mien l'oise
après onze ans de gabegie et le mével
gestion socialiste et ses départements
ce département situé dans cette belle et
grande région nord pas de calais
picardie est un département comme pour
tous les départements que nous avons
basculé où nous devons être exemplaires
parce que le message et les engagements
que nous avons pris auprès des électeurs
doivent être visibles respecter et
rapidement parce qu inutile de vous dire
qu'on peut pas faire campagne aux
régionales dans trois mois si l'on n'est
pas capable de démontrer qu'on a déjà
commencé à transformer la gestion dans
les départements dans lesquels on nous a
fait confiance au mois de mars dernier
et c'est ce que nous nous employons de
faire en particulier dans mon
département des choses simples comme
beaucoup d'élus
je n'ai cessé d'entendre dans mes
permanences des gens qui arrivaient vers
moi en me disant monsieur courtial ou
parfois même
parce qu'on m'appelle aussi comme ça et
bien explique moi pourquoi moi qui me
lève tous le matin ch à marc philippe
daubresse on en a parlé ensemble qui me
lève tôt le matin qui prend le train qui
subit le retard qui vais travailler qui
rentrent le soir épuisé et bien au final
à la fin du mois mon rêve mon revenu net
ce qui me reste pour vivre est inférieur
à celui qui est resté chez lui
tranquillement devant la télévision en
bénéficiant des prestations sociales et
bien face à face à ça nous dans l'oise
on a mis en place quelque chose de très
simple une cellule anti fraude au rsa en
particulier parce que celles et ceux qui
reçoivent de l'argent de la collectivité
payé par vos impôts ont le devoir de ne
pas trahir la règle c'est la moindre des
choses qu'on doit aux contribuables
français qui souffrent tellement
aujourd'hui nous l'avons dit nous
l'avons fait s'agissant des jeunes nous
avons même voulu décliner ce concept de
droits et de devoirs
nous avons mis en place le pass permis
en réalité dans mon département avant et
ça c'est la grande magie des socialistes
et de distribuer de l'argent qu'ils
n'ont pas il donnait des aides au permis
de conduire aux jeunes sous condition de
ressources mais sans aucune contrepartie
et avec ma majorité
on est parti d'un principe simple c'est
que c'était un passage évidemment
extrêmement important pour l'emploi des
jeunes qui puisse être mobile il fallait
continuer à les aider à passer le permis
de conduire
mais l'aide qu'on leur donne s'adresse à
toutes et tous mais à une seule
condition c'est qu'il donne 70 heures de
leur temps à la collectivité aux
associations d'handicapés pour aider les
personnes âgées
dans la vie on n'a rien sans rien
est ce que nous avons fait dans l'oise
où ce qui se fait dans beaucoup d'autres
départements que nous avons conquis au
mois de mars dernier et essentiel je
voulais 10 pour préparer la grande
reconquête des régions et ce sera j'en
suis persuadé comme marc philippon lundi
une fin d'année couronnée de succès pour
les républicains salle sera ici en
particulier en nord-pas-de-calais
picardie où nous avons l'un des
meilleurs le meilleur candidat possible
j'ai nommé xavier bertrand c'est un
local de l'étape il est né et il a
grandi il vit dans la grande région
il se démène il se démène sans compter
sur le terrain et vous l'avez forcément
croisé dans noces un département et lui
présente cet avantage d'aller au bout de
la démarche de s'engager continuellement
à la différence du candidat mystère
pardon marc-philippe mais du candidat
mystère du parti socialiste dont je
n'arrive même plus à me souvenir le nom
est en tout cas autrement aussi que
celle qu'on présente comme un
épouvantail qui est marine le pen qui en
définitive connaît notre région
uniquement par les etr du ta liste qui
l'emmène à bruxelles et même le pen elle
est beaucoup moins préoccupé par la
conquête des régionales on a
l'impression qu'elle est candidate parce
qu'ils comme quelqu'un qui monte sur
l'échafaud et elle ne voulait pas
vraiment y aller elle est beaucoup moins
préoccupé par cette campagne que par le
règlement de sombre affaire de famille
en définitive elle essaye d'éviter que
serait écrit bhl scénario d'un mauvais
film au sein du front national
c'est-à-dire papy fait de la résistance
alors mes chers amis je les dis
cette campagne des régionales ici
évidemment mais dans toutes les régions
de france suppose l'engagement de
chacune et chacun d'entre nous au
maximum en réalité c'est le dernier
grand rendez-vous électoral avant
l'année majeur que sera 2010 est et nous
avons besoin de votre engagement plus
que jamais nous avons besoin de
continuer à montrer aux français que
nous sommes déterminés que nous
entendons leur message que nous allons
au combat et que ce que nous disons dans
les campagnes nous le faisons à près à
la gestion de nos collectivités
ce sera majeur je les dis pour assurer
2017 comme une année de victoire mais je
sais pouvoir compter sur votre
engagement individuel chacune et chacun
d'entre nous à quelque niveau que nous
soyons dans le parti nous avons une
responsabilité individuelle parfois
simplement autour de nous dans nos
familles
parfois quand nous sommes de grands élus
évidemment en signant dans la france
mais nous avons ce devoir là ce devoir
de parent d'apporter une solution
crédible aux françaises et aux français
qui souffrent tellement de cette non
présidence de monsieur long et monsieur
hollande il faut pas se tromper
monsieur hollande vous l'avez même
compris cette semaine c'était pas qui
veut gagner des millions
c'était à qui je peux donner des
milliards parfois un le lundi parfois 2
le mercredi
bref il en train d'essayer de redonner
un peu de milliards mais bien peu de
chose par rapport aux dizaines de
milliards qu'il a piqué dans les poches
des contribuables français
depuis 2012 et donc ça nous montre bien
sa détermination à repartir au combat et
il ne va rien lâcher monsieur londres
rien ou plutôt si des promesses des
mensonges comme il l'a toujours fait et
il se dit au fond de lui-même
on sait jamais sur un malentendu ça peut
marcher
et ils auraient tort de passy penser
mais ça veut donc dire que nous nous
devons rester concentrés nous devons
rester axé sur cette première échéance
majeure que sont les régionales ici
particulièrement au nord pas de calais
picardie mais partout évidemment en
france
monté aux français que la famille des
républicains est définitivement
rassemblé que nous ne portons pas les
fruits de la division que nous sommes
dans le débat d'idées dans le débat
d'idées pour l'alternance pour faire une
vraie offre politique au service de la
république et de la france merci